joining us now kellyanne conway former
senior counselor to president trump
author of here's the deal
kellyanne um they're obviously trotting
out this talking point we called it out
i think on monday they're gonna they're
gonna say it's all putin's fault all the
way into the midterms
are americans ultimately going to buy
this when we start seeing those fuel
bills come in and the air conditioning
costs for the summer
no laura in fact americans know that
everything they basically said is not
true they've all been lies the border
surge was not seasonal
it's the record they've created records
there inflation was not transitory it's
here to stay the cpi today as you put
pointed out 7.9 percent the buying
administration continues to break all
these records in all the wrong ways and
it's not just partisan saying this it's
all the polls saying this particularly
independents who have really migrated
away from joe biden and kamala harris's
lack of accomplishments there's very
little confidence in their competence
and every poll out there shows major
disapproval majority disapproval on the
handling of all these diverse issues
from immigration to inflation to the
crisis in ukraine to obviously
what we're paying at the in the grocery
store the gas pump the supply chain
crisis and joe biden he has this way
jenn saki of playing the blame and game
name and shame
nonsense of washington but it would rely
on the american people believing it and
they've lost credibility not just in
their message and their messengers you
know laura i like to say the democrats
don't have this administration doesn't
have
a messaging problem they have a fact
problem and is reflected in the polls
they don't seem to do anything well
finally blaming putin for the gas prices
completely
forgets that gases was about two dollars
a gallon on election day 2020. now it's
more than doubled now and it had gone up
40 percent before russia invaded ukraine
hakeem jefferies at the democratic
retreat is telling everybody oh it's
putin's fault it's not and none of it
works people are smarter than that and
people are fearful yeah fearful i think
i think people are
if they're just now beginning to really
see
the increased cost of living across the
board on everything they buy and the
summer season is going to be expensive
but the media kellyanne not surprising
to you but the media especially cnn are
circling the wagons and trying to say
that this is really a narrative that
needs to be explained so we have to
explain the reasons for sacrifice to the
american people watch
many politicians act as though
it's president biden who caused
inflation and that he can fix this can
he do something about it well he can do
things at the margins but no i mean you
know he did not cause the war which
caused prices to surge now inflation was
already rising for sure we had supply
chain issues some of that was actually
because of good news meaning a really
strong recovery
kellyanne inflation was good news what
it's never good news and in fact people
know presidents can do that we recently
had a president who did keep all of
those cost of living measures down we
know that the tax cut and jobs act at
the end of 2017 unleashed so much so
much prosperity repatriated all that
money back that was overseas and you
know laura this country is suffering
there's a lot of uncertainty chaos
insecurity because of these policies you
cannot kill 42 000 energy jobs on day
one of your administration and out the
door with that goes 800 000 barrels per
day in in domestic oil production and
convince people that it's not your fault
you can't have supply chain crisis when
people see the containers stuck
on our own waterways you can't have a
president who looks the other way when
people and drugs are coming over our
southern border who just this past
tuesday laura two days ago said his
budget next year will include 2.6
billion dollars for gender equality he's
saying that in the middle of sending
kamala harris to poland so people are
smart they're smart to this and this is
a guy who gave 85 billion dollars of our
intelligence and our equipment left it
in china's wingspan after his chaotic
and deadly withdrawal from afghanistan
people know it i think the moms the moms
are going to rise up in november the
moms pay the bills the family bills and
i think the that the wrath of mothers on
a whole bunch of issues is going to be
felt kellyanne great to see you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else